so Louis I want to start with you I said
you without you if you hadn't laid words
down on paper and told this story we
wouldn't be here and it's a story that
look we have commandos it's a story that
resonates very deeply with people and I
was curious what some of the more
surprising reactions are that you've
gotten over the years from readers
who've seen something in the story and
do they ever see anything that you
yourself are surprised to find actually
the most surprising reaction I've gotten
over the years and still get I won't get
it anymore after this movie it's out
there is the people who think the boy
and the baby are dead at the end of the
book they are not folks they're alive
and well and there are three more books
if you want to read about what happens
to them later but it's clear at the end
of this movie that not only are they're
alive and well but they have they have
returned a kind of sanity to this
community that they've fled but why do
you think the story connects so deeply
with people there's more to it than just
an exciting adventure I'm still asking
or do you disagree do I disagree no I
think there's a great deal more to it
but interestingly when I wrote the book
I wrote it just as a story as an
exciting adventure as you say it was
only afterwards that I realized out of
that arises food for thought a lot of
questions are raised I think the best
books raise questions rather than give
answers I think the best books don't
have messages because there are
different answers to those questions and
so I think that's what the book The
Giver does and it's why teachers liked
it so much because it raises those
questions for students probably a few of
you out here had to read it
so Jeff you uh you star in the film but
you've been pushing this project along
for almost 20 years now forever you you
forever you you got interested early on
tell us about discovering the novel and
and what it was that inspired you to say
I want to make a movie out of this
originally I wanted to direct my father
Lloyd Bridges in a film and I wanted to
direct him in a film that my kids could
see and they were little kids back in
those days they're all in their you know
30 and so I got myself a catalog of
children's books and I saw this great
cover with this grizzled old guy on the
cover and the Newbery Award there
stamped on the cover I thought oh this
is this could be a good one let me let
me pick this book up oh and by the way I
found out later that Lois took that
photograph which I love so much anyway I
thought I'll get in this book this will
be a wonderful book to read and I read
it and it was a terrific children's book
but also I enjoyed it so much as an
adult and found the themes you know so
important and and the poetry of it
really you know I just I just loved so I
thought oh this is gonna be an easy one
you know to get made but I was mistaken
we tried for you know close to eight no
1819 years to get it mad and it proved
to be difficult I think because it was
quite a controversial of Lois and I not
too long ago we're in Las Vegas and a
banned book conference and the book was
banned in many areas in many places but
also it was taught in many schools how
many of you guys out there you know read
the book in school was like mandatory
yeah huh look at that not while so that
you know that that that controversy I
think scared some finance years away but
it also inspired me I said a while ago
so you know the energy of this thing you
know being the Pope the two poles you
know people saying oh it's too too risky
you know we do want to show our kids
that and the other ones oh yeah this is
the kind of thing we want our kids to
learn so I'm so glad that the Weinstein
Company and Walt and finally get the
courage to put it out I don't understand
the the controversy and why anyone would
want to ban this story Louis what what's
the reasoning never actually figured it
out myself because often people take
things out of context there are two
scenes in the book that would be held up
as this is disgusting we don't want our
children to read this what is the scene
you just saw part of in the little film
clip where the father kills the infant
that's a difficult scene it's important
to the book and you can understand why
why people are unnerved by the other not
in the movie is of scene where the boy
12 in the book bathes an old woman so
there's the 12 year old boy with a naked
woman and I loved it when when that
scene was cut from the film Louis I know
you were very disappointed because you
wanted to play your father was the was
your original idea of the giver and you
started to look like that grizzled old
guy
oh you mentioned she you [ __ ] who shot
the photo who we all know that cover
those who read the book early on now it
has the new the new movie poster cover
but the who was that old man oh they'll
look man who's long dad was named karl
gustav nelson he was a painter and at
the time i was a journalist a photo
journalist and i had an assignment from
a magazine to write an article about him
so i went and spent time with him
photographed him and i remember when his
photograph was floating in my darkroom
sink one of my kids watch passed glanced
at it and said who's that moses and so i
wrote him to thank him for the time we'd
spent together and i told him that and
we cursed wanted for some years and he
always signed his letters love moses
he's gone now and he was gone when the
book was written so he didn't ever get
to see himself as it as a cover on a
book mickey you've worked with jeff for
a long time and this is he said i've
been a project that he's been developing
forever tell us about the turning point
what was it that happen that finally
gave the giver the green light well in
everything there's always luck and
timing and you know Jeff's continual
persistence as we went through this and
I don't clearly it's been quite a
journey and I think there all of a
sudden became an appetite a real
appetite for this whole genre of
dystopian fiction that you know Louis I
always call her the birth mother
this whole genre of literature that's
out there right now and so it was a
combination of timing that finally was
right and Louis is continual faith in us
and not giving up and then the vision
for how we could take this book and make
it into this amazing piece that has
action and it's interesting and so we
were really excited with Walden and
Weinstein or the perfect combination of
companies to come together so that's
interesting some of the novels that were
inspired by The Giver ended up clearing
the path for The Giver to go to the
screen
it happens that way sometimes
interesting yeah it symbiotic
relationship can you talk about the
casting of the film and about an actress
who you saw in the footage but it's not
here Meryl Streep as elder chief Elbert
I mean our chief elder - I mean it was
to have you know the two top actors of
our generation you know acting together
and Jeff you and Marilyn never acted
together before right uh we were
Merrill's like a soccer mom right but
our kids in soccer together so I knew
her but I had never worked with him
before and it was a you know real thrill
and you have a number of scenes together
especially at the end where you two go
good and we would just sit on set and
watch the two of them go and everybody
just stopped I mean it was just it was
amazing right I mean just watching the
two of them and the clash of their two
ideologies at the end and it just builds
the music's pumping and it's fantastic
so we I mean Merrill Merrill uh she's
one of a kind Jeff can I just add
something I want to say this happens
rarely but but I realized after seeing
what I've seen of the work I haven't
seen the total film yet I realized I
wanted to go back and rewrite the book
and I wanted to make the role of the
chief elder into what it is playing the
role because in the book it's it's a
small role and the personality of the
chief elder is not displayed she makes
it into something so complex and so
fascinating and and she is really the
political leader and Jeff the spiritual
leader and the conflict between them
which is not unfortunately in the book I
wish I could go back let's talk about
what happened with this character
because she's not a traditional villain
she's not out to do evil she really
believes in that in the mission that
they've set forth a clear suffering away
from it's actually the same thing that
happens when people try to ban the book
they're not evil people
they're people who care about their
children and want to protect their
children I always try to remember that
when they write me letters saying Jesus
would be ashamed of you
this is a good person who wants to
protect her child and same thing with
this role for Meryl and how wonderful a
powerful woman running the society hmm
make her eat made her evil bow to stern
different things so a Brenton you've had
a pretty big year
Maleficent Angelina Jolie's in that and
Jenelle Fanning and now you're in The
Giver with another elder statesman Jeff
Bridges can you tell us about just
moving from Whitley you shot
Maleficent first and then the giver or
sometimes these get the the shooting
gets mixed up in the film that you shot
last doesn't always come out first so
what order was it did you two go right
from Maleficent into The Giver
Maleficent was a long time ago that was
three years ago Wow this was a quick
turnaround from shooting it coming out
yes which is crazy Maleficent I think it
took two and a half years to come out
it's it's kind of it's cool to to be
here this year to watch them all come to
life because you you know life on set is
very different and very monotonous not
monotonous but like Groundhog Day good
it's a different scene you know than you
and it desert getting chased by a snake
or something yeah it's interesting this
whole experience is cool and it'll be
really really cool to see what you guys
think of the movie was there a
particular scene and the giver that you
were most looking forward to shooting I
just couldn't wait to get to that
particular part in the script I mean I
was really excited too
he touched me bright nice in real life
touch me oh she's ready for her bath you
can't you guys read this sinuses please
be aware that there are many members of
our audience that are under 18 years of
age we're getting a little racy here now
who's the chief elder yes protect the
children so today you you you portray
Fiona and in the story she's much
younger than you actually are what do
you think adding a few years to the
character for the purpose of the film
actually does to maybe change the
perspective of her or does it not at all
I think it does because in the book when
Jonas starts to develop feelings he
starts to develop feelings for Fiona and
it's kind of a crush because it's you
know feelings can only go like to an
extent as a 12 year old but when you're
1617 I think it's much more severe and
when he falls in love with her he
realizes how cruel this society actually
is so it just makes the injections and
the community seem even more harsh Louis
said earlier that the book she thinks
the book makes a connection because it
raises questions that people have I
guess it makes the racist questions it
makes you feel not so alone that you're
asking the same questions well what at
the book what connection did you make
with the book when you first read it I
think it just for me it just really hit
me of how incredible life is and how
much we have to cherish certain moments
a lot of memories that the Jonas
receives and holidays and just things
like being warm and being cold and
things that we take for granted and she
kind of put that message in subtly and a
lot of times as kids our parents always
tell us appreciate this moment
appreciate the
moment cuz we're trying to grow up and
we're we're not really realizing how
good things are and but you know it's
easier said than done and this book
really hits you it's much different
Brendan how about you what yeah she was
like be happy smile Brendan what kind of
feelings of the story stirring you in
you first laid eyes on I guess I'm just
really connected with Jonas no I read
the screenplay before the book and and I
just I guess I was really attracted to
his journey and now he's he finds you
know imperative moments throughout the
story he learns such deep visceral
emotions from the giver and that kind of
teaches him to trust his instincts and
follow his heart and I always felt like
the you know any kind of pain or suffer
you want to take those sharp edges take
those jagged edges off of your life if
you can but that leads to kind of a dull
existence doesn't it the the price of
comfort you know what we are how much
was willing to pay to be comfortable and
that can also kind of that can often
backfire one of the richness in life
comes out of the struggle over yourself
right now one of the things that people
sometimes don't notice right away is
that in this world where Jonas lives
among the things they've lost our art
and music and literature and the reason
for that is that those things always
arise out of pain and once they've
obliterated the painful part of life
they've lost it very great deal and love
to you know that great song you know
love hurts you know it does sometimes
but look what else it does but I also
think that there's probably not a person
in this room who at one point in their
life didn't say I'd give it all up it
could just be easy I give it all up and
that's really the question that the
movie yes I mean I think we've all gone
through time so it's like oh but so
Merrill's arguments a real argument
that's what makes the book exciting
that's what makes the movie exciting -
absolutely well let's open it up to the
audience you guys have some questions
for this bunch let's let's take a few
questions from the audience
and if if you're the shy type it's not
likely to get up out of your seat and go
to the microphone and you want to ask
something tweet me a message my twitter
handle is my last name @b r ez n ICA N
and I'll ask it for you so for the shy
persons out there they can get their
question asked too but let's take a
question from the microphone
hey I found out but fair that Jonas
wasn't dead cuz she's sitting gathering
blue he survives are you gonna do a
gathering for the movie good question
will there be a sequel to The Giver
following your other books I don't know
that there's been talk of it but I think
probably that decision will wait until
we see how the audience reacts to this
movie it would be fun to to embark on a
new one but I don't think that decision
will be made for a while any other
questions Oh your mics not on tell the
people who want to ban your book to go
live and Ray Bradbury's Fahrenheit 451
Society next question hi my name is Aida
and this is a question for Luis Laurie
and I was wondering would you consider
your book a dystopian when you wrote it
and also do you think that how do you
think other dystopian worlds compare
since you wrote the book
I assume it's question is for me yeah I
don't tend to think in that kind of
terms when I write a book I I began to
create a story a character appears to me
I move him through a journey that he has
to make and it wasn't until I was fairly
far along in the book that I realized
this book was going to be have going to
have to be set in the future I also of
course began to realize that I hadn't
really known this at first that the
place where he lives is not such a
wonderful place I began to to create a
place that seemed pretty neat to me I
would have liked to live there
but then of course as it became more
complicated it then turns into what is
called a dystopia
a place that appears on the surface to
be wonderful and you turn the rock over
and there's all the ugly stuff
underneath but that wasn't on my mind
Asian dystopian was not on my mind and
it was only later that that course
people began to call the book that and
then all of these many many other
dystopian novels began to appear in the
years after the giver so we have a
question from the audience Gretchen
asked through Twitter for Louis how hard
was it to get the giver published it was
not difficult because I've been doing
this work for a very long time and I'd
probably published 20 books before The
Giver I'd had the same publisher the
same editor for all those books so when
I finished writing The Giver I simply
gave the manuscript to that editor it
was unlike my other books he was
surprised by it and therefore he showed
it to other editors at the publishing
company and together they came to the
decision to publish it but because I had
a track record it wasn't difficult to to
get it published next question here oh
sorry
my name is Renato this question is for
Lois Lowry I read all of your books and
I loved your series the questions for
the fourth book son where did you get
your inspiration for the character train
master he appears in an earlier book the
third of the series trade masters a
truly evil guy he's the personification
of evil you know I'm trying to think
back and I don't want to talk too much
about the other books cuz hey guys we're
here for the movie and and the other
books aren't movies yet
so that was just a character appeared to
me when I was writing the third book and
needed a villain and there he was and he
also represents a villainous part of all
of our lives he's the guy who appears
and says you want whatever what will you
trade for it and people begin to give
away important parts of themselves in
order to get stuff and isn't that what
all of us do from time to time we make
those terrible compromises so that's
where he came from from us and from the
people we know
so JB from the audience asks Louis or
the any of the memories that the giver
gives to Jonas things that were special
to you in your real life oh you should I
can answer that also but we should ask
the other people as well because of
course all of our memories are are
different it was the role of the
director I suppose more than anybody
else and he unfortunately isn't here
who put together the montage of memories
which is beautifully done in the film I
entreated only one and maybe it would
have come to him anyway but I emailed
him at one point when I'd seen an early
version of it and I said you ought to
have some scene from the world of Islam
in there and so it's it's now there but
there's just wonderful scenes of every
bit of emotion filled experience that
we've all seen and had in our lives
Nicky can you talk a little bit about
how those were decided upon and how they
were put together well we started really
big and then we wanted to go small
because at the end of the day it's like
what what are the things what is what is
being alive really mean to you and it
was you know there was a lot for us the
set was a really very happy place I mean
these guys are all musical there was a
night with this these three over here
that they're playing guitar and she
sings and all of that sort of brought to
us kind of the essence of what it's
about
I mean I think you know trying to show
Humanity music living tears happiness
right Jeff yeah yeah we had a great time
that's great yeah oh we all jammed a lot
of music and we had Taylor Swift onboard
you know between between the set outs we
get out the guitar how did she get
involved in the movie in in fact Maddie
from the audience asked that questions
we we actually wrote the character as a
piano playing character before Taylor
was cast and the executives in The
Weinstein Company weren't one of her
shows and had this crazy idea I said
maybe this would make sense and talk to
her about it and she came on board and
she came down we were all in South
Africa which is an amazing place you
should all go when you have a chance and
she came down to South Africa and in the
book that character is talked about and
described but she's already gone by the
time the book begins in the movie given
the magic of technology they're able to
you can see her and she reappears to the
giver because he's she's very special to
him it was the microphone let's hear
your question I love you your amazing
writer and I've read a bunch of your
books
but I was you had mentioned that there
were you wanted to go back and change
the chief elder like in your book is
there anything else in your book that
you would like to be go back and change
any of them if you could you know after
I write a book every book I've written
they're things so I wish I had done
better I wonder if the actress would
like to redo certain scenes all the time
all the time yeah every time
but as far as the giver is concerned
that and having seen parts of the movie
I haven't seen the whole thing yet it
was that particular thing that I would
like to go back and reinsert or insert
into into the novel I can't think of
anything else in particular except that
as you know and as you can see from the
actress here the kids are slightly older
in the movie I don't know that I'd like
to go back and rewrite the book to make
the kids older I think it works them
being 12 and I'm not sure why the
decision was made to make them older but
it was a concern of mine that that that
was happening and then the first time I
saw the beginning of the movie which I
think you saw here to tonight today the
children the kids the teenagers on their
bikes I thought oh yeah it works because
the boy and you see him close up in the
opening of the film right away you see
that he is the same as the 12 year old
boy in that he's young he's he's curious
he's intelligent he's vulnerable and so
it doesn't matter that he's a few years
older it works quite well next question
Mike hello my question is for the dude I
sorry I know you worked very heavily on
this movie you've been working on it for
more than 10 years right even had a
vision for who the giver was but instead
you were casted as yourself so my
question is when you were making a
character did you stick to source
material or was it more based on the new
script the new style of the movie yeah I
was so enamored of the book I was trying
to always always go back to the book
it's wonderful to make a film that's
based on a book because scripts are very
condensed in a very little description
and with a book you can you know really
get inside the character and so I would
always I would constantly reference the
book you know when we were when we'd
have a scene to shoot
you know with the the next day that
night I would look and see where it was
in the book you know to see you know how
that how that would you know inform the
scene so Lala tweets under the handle
Briona pancakes she just thought that
was interesting she asked a Brenda and
uh okay uh how for as young actress
starring in this film what advice you
have for other up-and-coming young
performers I would say for any film
theater gig you get or do just go in
with an open heart and be willing to try
things and throw ideas out and and be
fearless in your approach as one of the
things that Taylor came up with you know
into quite a stressful environment I was
shooting very quickly you know she came
in very fearless and throwing ideas out
and taking things on and I think that's
just the best way to approach anything
really creative it's just put yourself
out there and try and commit to things
you know yeah I completely agree and
also I think just take every opportunity
you have I came from Haifa Israel and
lived in Alabama for two years and to
never think that I'd be up here after
only acting for such a short amount of
time and I think some saying it is
possible and you should do plays at
school write your own plays try to you
know go see as many movies as you can do
everything you can because this is
possible because I'm living it right now
also you know I think you know we got
these specific we got back we have you
know we have cell phones and jeez you
know you guys can make your own movies
you know just make a make a movie pull a
rocky you know like Sylvester did
what's that yeah yeah and put that do
remember my brother Bo when I was
starting out those about eight years
older than I am and he came up with this
great idea
you know Xan
you're looking for places you know where
I might do my stuff you know and so Bo
came up with this idea to rent a flatbed
truck and we would work up some scenes
and then we would pull into a
supermarket and our father taught us how
this fake fight and stage fire and we
would stage this fight each other and
the crowd would come around they would
say no we're kidding it's a show and we
jump up on the the back of this track
and we do our scenes until the cops
would come and they mean we try to we
try to improv the cops like they were
part of the show they didn't you know
threaten us and then we say okay we go
to the next supermarket and we played
the supermarket circuit Jeff Bridges is
advice for how to get arrested
how'd I get arrested in Hollywood right
when you first gotten actually not with
Bo but when I first wanted my father to
be in the in this film I thought well
let's just let's read the book so I got
my buddy bud cort do you guys know who
bud cort is Harold and Maude Maude and
this is like you know back you know 1819
years ago and so I asked him to narrate
that narrate the story my dear nephew
who is here somewhere at comic-con he
works from now for universal but at the
time he was about 10 years old he played
Jonas he played your part my father was
the giver and we have this document
somewhere in some garage and I'm hoping
that we will find it by the time we're
putting the DVD together to be an extra
thing another thing you're just
mentioning just mentioning the book I
remember it was a it was a one of the
first things we did I thought it would
be helpful we gathered the cast together
and we read the book together out loud I
don't know did you know that Lois that
we did that I think you've told yeah and
that we saw it was really helpful you
everybody on the same in the same same
idea had you made the film with your
father Lloyd Bridges as the giver would
you have taken a role in the film as
well which might you have played the
Alexander Skarsgard character of the
father no I was gonna I mean my plan was
I was in the director mm-hmm yeah young
lady here at the microphone hi my name
is Rebecca and this questions for Lois
Lowry what inspired the idea of having
your outsider be chosen by the community
and have it be considered an honor can
you repeat what your no I just was
hoping you would repeated I sort of
didn't hear the second half let her says
okay I was looking at tweets some good
question then what inspired your idea of
having the outsider be chosen by the
community itself and having it be
considered an honor
boy it's always hard to be asked what
inspired a particular thing when a book
is 20 years old because then I have to
try to go back and to my mind 20 years
ago and that's hard I will say though
that I think it's fair to say that every
book the main character the protagonist
male or female of every book at least
every book by me is usually an outsider
one of the things they have to fight
against I bet everybody in this room
because of this particular convention
and who you are and some of you are in
costumes
you probably think of yourself as
Outsiders I would guess
I always have and so so it feels natural
to me to project myself in my mind my
thoughts into that of an individual who
is set apart for in some fashion
it makes for a more interesting
character I think if nothing else next
question for the mic
hello um my questions form this Larry
sorry I'm a little nervous by the book
when I was so young I just started
crying when the trailer played
you've been such an inspiration and my
question is for you I know you touched
on it a little bit earlier where when
you did the book to screen adaptation
were there any scenes that you really
wanted in the movie a point that you
wanted people get out of it or any
message like what did you want people or
what would you want people to come away
with it I think I said earlier that I
think the best books and probably the
best movies raise questions and that the
different people who read or see a book
or a movie probably have their
individual answers to those questions I
don't feel so it's my role to provide
answers but I think it's exhilarating to
provide questions but Lance from the
audience I guess would be a follow-up to
that which what kind of input did you
have on the film not necessarily telling
what answers to provide but what kind of
guidance did you give to Jeff as a
producer and Nicki as a producer and in
Philip as a director or any of the
actors III didn't provide any guidance
at all to any of them because they're
all professionals who are very good at
what they do but I did occasionally
provide little details Philip the
director is an email addict would you
say addict and also he seems never to
sleep so 24 hours a day he's sending
emails to all of us and beginning way
back a year ago he began emailing me
with small questions as an example what
what should the boys bedroom look like
clearly they were beginning to think
about set design what should Janice's
bedroom look like probably the time on
his email was 2 a.m. but I would have
gotten it the next morning
and so I wrote back and I said it would
be very stuck there would be it would be
functional there would be a bed some
place to keep his clothes there would be
a desk for him to do his homework but
there wouldn't be anything decorative if
you want anything to hang on the walls
probably it should be something
educational
maybe I suggested a poster showing the
periodic table of elements okay which he
would be studying of course in school
I'd later mentioned that to my then 12
year old grandson but this is how I
described the boys bedroom my grandson
had read the book and my grandson said
this book is set when 50 years from now
and I said well yeah perhaps and he said
well there's not gonna be any more
helium by then who knew
it's my 12 year old grandson and he said
also there will be new elements that
haven't been discovered yet
I said well tough if you're under 18
years of age close your ears tough [ __ ]
I said and actually I've forgotten no I
was in Cape Town I did look at the set
for the boys bedroom but it was dark
Randy is a flashlight because the scenes
had already been shot there so I don't
remember if that was on was that on the
do you remember anything on the wall of
the bedroom
I honestly it was a tree I think yeah
it's the tree that tell I heard that you
during the ADR sessions you know when we
were working on the sound that you gave
Meryl Streep's some line readings on how
to perform certain line were you singing
Meryl Streep and how to ask Louis she
this isn't a studio in New York and
she's recording I don't know the
terminology but she's recording some
dialogue and there is a scene at the end
I don't believe this was part of the
clip here but she says to Jeff who was
not there but this and the scene had
already been filmed so it's being
projected and she is recording her
dialogue over the projection
and she says originally he says you
could stop this she says stop what and
and then she says if you don't want to
watch close your eyes go sit down with
the other elders I said wait a minute
he's not Helen Keller he's supposed to
close his eyes and then go sit down with
the other elders it should say go sit
down with the other elders if you don't
want to watch close your eyes and so she
redid it and did that fit because she
already shot it you've got to match the
first I want to say that a Lois Lowry
book never felt like required reading so
thank you very much Jo thing my question
is for Jeff as obviously such a huge fan
of the book you know we're talking about
movie adaptations and changes
sadly the bathtub scene had to be cut
but was there anything in particular
that you fought for or 20 years ago you
saw it a certain way and the age of the
kids you know I was I was one of those
ones who said no we got to keep him you
know 12 and I was you know really
actually I came to a point and when I
had to decide whether I was going to
stay on board or just you know wish
everybody good luck because I knew it
wasn't going to be how I pictured it as
I said before it one time I was thinking
about directing it so I had a lot of
opinions as the dude would say that's
just my opinion man
if I had a lot of you know and a lot of
them and and then I decided you know I
sometimes hope when I come to Forks in
the road like that I think you know I
kind of project myself in the future and
I try to imagine what this would be like
if I turned this down you know boy but
if I turned it down it just didn't feel
right at all so I decided to just jump
on board knowing that it was going to be
very different but I was going to kind
of roll with it and you know kind of
take it as it comes and I knew there
were talented people involved and just
to kind of go with it and then this guy
shows up and this beautiful lady here
and they did you know I could tell you
early on oh yeah I was I was wrong I was
wrong you know it's wonderful to be
wrong
yes because there's some other thing he
said maybe I was wrong about that and do
you know and maybe Nicky is one day ask
yourself why they decided to make it
yeah well you know there's lotteries one
of the reasons I think right neck you
said you know just a financial thing if
you got a young kid you can't work in
this card and we were we worked our
butts off on this one beating your hour
and maybe segwaying from that we should
talk about what it's like to work in a
movie with a lot of babies to carry a
baby around for a very long time yeah
how many different babies was this a
case we had like triplets and they would
swap out twins William Mann Alexander
James and Alex Eames and Alex there's
those babies they did such a wonderful
job
aren't they great I mean just far is
just acting but there's no acting that's
but they as what they tell you you know
when you're doing a movie they don't act
it just kind of do it and babies really
an really an acting lesson to watch how
effortless if you if you want someone to
play a baby hire an actual baby you know
they know it but in addition to the baby
Gabe who Jonas
takes when he leaves the community there
are a lot of other babies because Jonas
and
work in the nurturing Center and so
there are many bassinets filled with
babies and there were many women in Cape
Town willing to bring their babies to to
be in those bassinets and they were also
should we let them know there was some
fake babies you know my my first acting
role with no actual babies were I my
first role was when I was a baby six
months old and I was in this movie with
wonderful actress Jane Greer John
Cromwell was directing and my parents
were I'm consulting I got into a long
story I'll see if I can make this short
well you're as good as the baby in this
movie I don't know I have to learn from
this child but they needed a baby and I
was kind of a happy baby but the baby
and this one needed to cry and so unlike
our babies my mother told the the
actress Jane Greer oh just pinch him
he'll cry that's the world and well so
now we cut about thirty-five years later
and I'm in a movie another movie with
Jane Greer a remake of a great movie she
made with Robert Mitchum called out of
the past I was was called against all
odds and she's playing she's playing her
character of the originals her just by
her mother now and they say Jim you just
give me I'm having some emotional
problem it gave me a little piece it's
gonna get me going
long story sighs well I want to thank
you guys all so much you've got a great
audience thank you to these makers and
the stars of The Giver
you